ça fait des mois qu'on utilise du
désinfectant pour les mains plusieurs
fois par jour
le problème c'est que le processus pour
les produire est vraiment compliqué il
faut qu'il soit pur efficace et
sécuritaire
regardez cette liste c'est celle des
rappels de santé canada pour les
produits de désinfectant pour les mains
plus de 100 au total depuis le début de
la pandémie
et si vous regardez de plus près la
plupart du temps c'est à cause d'un
mauvais étiquetage mais aussi de la
présence de produits potentiellement
dangereux pour la santé comme de la ceta
d'éthyle ou du méthanol un manager match
au début de la pandémie
santé canada a autorisé l'usagé de
l'éthanol de qualité technique sous
contrôle strict et soyons clairs tout de
même sur une chose sur la plupart
d'entre nous lusage de l'éthanol de
qualité technique n'aura aucune
incidence
mais il ne faut pas que ce produit soit
ingérée et problèmes qu'on remarque ces
derniers temps c'est que le nombre
d'empoisonnement par ingestion a
augmenté le centre antipoison de
l'ontario qui traite des cas au manitoba
et au nunavut également a reçu des
appels de 314 passion de juin à
septembre chez les moins de 19 ans pour
empoisonnement avec des désinfectants
pour les mains contre 96 l'an dernier et
la majorité de ces appels concernaient
des enfants de 5 ans et moins jeunes
enfants de l'âge de 6 ans c'est
important d'utiliser seulement sur la
cervelle en sit in à 2 est aussi
maintenant il ya des produits qui
ressemble au à eau sachez utiliser pour
les aliments aides et les boissons
alors pour les enfants ils savent pas
c'est quoi ils vont essayer de manger
alors que devez vous regardez
lorsque vous achetez un désinfectant
pour les mains et le choc the ring of
honor marie christine et vous pouvez
aussi regarder sur internet la liste des
désinfectants pour les mains autorisés
par santé canada
la solution la plus efficace reste tout
de même de se laver les mains avec de
l'eau et du savon
encore faut-il le faire correctement et
si vous n'avez pas cette possibilité
n'oubliez pas que la seule solution
demeure le désinfectant